There is no best thing to do in life
Anything that you take up?
And if you put your heart and soul into it it becomes a great thing if you want to be in a competitive situation
The thing is you have to work on your competence what worked for one person
We try to make it work for another person and destroy the person completely
Unfortunately, this is labeled as education
Need motivation watch atop tenant believe nation
What's up?
At seven my one word is believe and I believe in you I believe you have an amazing gift inside you that I want to
See explode out onto the world
So let's get your motivation to attend and get you
Believing in you grab a snack on chewing today's lessons from a man who went from moving around a lot as a kid and having
a passion for motorcycles and travel to then having a spiritual experience then he decided to dedicate his life to
Spirituality and starting the Isha Foundation. He sadguru, and here's my take on his top ten girls a success vol 3
joy
Alright let's kick things off with rule number one be passionate about everything. There are no right things to do in life
If you choose something and
Put everything that you have into it. It'll become a great thing is it the right thing is it the best thing?
When you say is it the right thing what you're asking is is it the best thing to do in life?
There is no best thing to do in life
Anything that you take up, and if you put your heart and soul into it it becomes a great thing
This is the best thing No
then what is the best thing there is no such thing don't look at yourself as a
Delhi 8 or an idiot whatever you want to call yourself
If you're just a piece of life hmm hello
And today you're here one day you'll be poop
dong
You are a brief life. I want you to just imagine you've seen those insects which come when it rains you know and switch fly
Suppose you are that?
You just came alive
Dong that's what you are
Just
compared to the span of your life the insects life is looking so meaningless and
poop and gone
That's what the rivers are thinking about you poopoo cupen gone
Yes or no
Compared to their lifespan you are just like that insect or less than an insect isn't it so I am NOT somebody who ever
Debated he is this the right thing to do in my life
What was needed I jumped into it?
because
If you are a constipated life you will always be thinking
About what to do what not to do what to do what not to do, what is my passion what is not my passion
Why the hell are you not passionate about everything?
Hello
Why are you not passionate about everything in the existence you're only passionate about one thing means what you constipated
That's what it means
Idiots do things that they don't like to do suffer for their whole life because they think it's needed or they think it's their duty
Intelligent people do
What they love to do
They enjoy their life to some extent
But a genius learns to do what is needed joyfully, that's when your genius flowers
Because it's no more about you now. There's a limitless way of looking at life
Rule number two be well managed if you try to control
The variety of situations that may pop up in your face tomorrow morning all that will happen is you will become a very limited life
You would step out into the world and do whatever that needs to be done only if you have an assurance no matter
What you walk into you will not lose yourself
You will walk full stride, otherwise you'll only be a half a step
Most human beings are half steps
Because the fear of suffering if this happens. What will happen to me if that happens
What will happen to me if you're well managed within yourself
You know how to manage your thought?
You know how to manage your emotion you know how to manage your body?
Your chemistry your energy if you know how to manage all this
What does it matter if you walk into hell?
I'm asking if you are well managed if you are a heaven within you what does it matter? Where you go?
Hell also will be an interesting place to go
But if you are ill managed
then you want to be in a nice place all the time you will not step out into anything I
Am NOT saying this is wrong this is against nature
Because in nature every life is aspiring to a B as much as it can be isn't it
Every life is naturally aspiring. This is not a philosophy
this is not an ideology, but you must do this or that it is natural and
Intrinsic for every life that you will do as much as it can
From an earthworm from a worm to an insect to a bird to an animal to a tree every one of them are
Trying to be full-fledged life
if you go against this
simply because of the fear of suffering
then all
Possibilities of exploring the nature of being human the tremendous immensity of being human is just lost upon humanity
Today you will see this everywhere when people say I am only human
They are talking about the limitations of being human. They are not talking about the possibilities of being human isn't it?
When if we are the most intelligent species on the planet if we are the most capable species on the planet?
Should we be talking about our possibilities, or should we be talking about our limitations?
Whenever anybody writes, or says oh?
We are human. They are always referring to their limitations never to the possibilities of being human
This is because the the most fundamental things have not been taught in our education systems
how to handle your thought and your emotion your
Psychological drama has gone out of control. It's a badly directed drama believe me
If we choose a well-directed drama you would take it to the conclusion that you want isn't it
Because it's a badly directed drama just about anybody can take charge of it
Who is the director of your psychological drama just about anybody isn't it?
Anybody can make it into your tragedy rule number three build your competence
Competition is a good thing
If you are incompetent and you're in competition you will feel stressed
If you want to be in a competitive situation the thing is you have to work on your competence
Right now the problem is
You're tweaking your desire. You're not tweaking your competence
This is what has to happen that we must teach children to tweak their competence not their desire
We are calling this ambition we calling this goal oriented Ness
Ambition means what you tweaked up your desire you will suffer invariably if you tweak up your competence
You will see wherever you go. You are doing better than what people expect you to
so naturally
Things will go well for you
Competition is not the bad thing lack of competence is the bad thing so instead of competence
We have big desires
If you focus enough on enhancing your competence you will see there is such joy in
Breaking limitations every day and becoming something better. You don't care a damn. How somebody else is doing rule number four
prioritize
Suppose, let's say you have to cook something. That's a you have to bake a cake or you want to cook some rice
You turn on this Tao turn off this tau 10 understand turn off this tap
It's a long process
And of course they know won't happen
So this is the story of
Majority of the spiritual seekers
there off and on and off and on and off and on Oh
Does it mean to say I must be only here there? That's not it the priority should not shift the
Priority is set
Slowly everything with the new will slowly organize itself in that direction
Because the priority is shifting this life does not know which way to go it is confused
Every two minutes if you change the destination on the GPS for sure it does not know where to go isn't it
So this is what is happening and for in most people. This is why a spiritual path seems to be order is long impossible
Unattainable all these things
Simply because people are shifting priorities all the time rule number five my personal favorite ride the wave of life
Is it true that every other creature on this planet a?
worm an insect a bird and animal
With a millionth of our brain they're conducting their life process quite well. Hello
Okay
when I say live process
We are born. They're born just like that
We grew up they grow up
We make a living they make a living we may reproduce they reproduce
We do all this with enormous fuss
They simply do it
Yes or no
Every simple thing we're doing it enormous fuss. They are simply doing it
Different various processes of life and death they are doing it without fuss. We are doing everything with great fuss
Is this a sign of highest level of intelligence I'm asking
We are supposed to be the most intelligent
And there is no question that we have the most evolved neurological process on the planet yes
we have the most evolved neurological system that we must be able to sense and feel and experience and
perceive
understand and express things in the highest possible way
But no other creature on the planet is struggling like the human creature right now
This is simply because
You have been given a super
Supercomputer do you agree with me that this is the most sophisticated?
gadget on the planet not the iPhone the eye
But now the question is have you read the user's manual
That's all people have not read the user's manual for the most complex machine on the planet and
Somehow blundering through somehow trying to use it
Everything is a problem. Tell me one thing that human beings are not suffering
If they're poor they suffer their poverty you make them rich they suffer the taxes
If they're not educated they suffer that put them to school lot of suffering
Not married they suffer that get them married I
Didn't say anything. I didn't say a thing okay
No children some people suffer that children daily suffering
So you seem to be suffering every aspect of life
So if you offer death will you go do I fully know you will suffer that?
So tell me one thing that we are not suffering now people we vilasa fees life is suffering
No, no life is not suffering
Nor is it a joy. It's simply there. It's a phenomena if you write it
It feels fantastic if you're crushed by it it feels terrible
So are you riding the wave of life, or are you being crushed by it?
That's all the question is rule number six be interested in people. I say this just a couple of weeks ago
I was in conversation with someone who is considered some kind of an expert on
Internet affairs and social media and all this
so
He's been looking at our material
In the YouTube and various other platforms, and I said me easily I can give you 50 times more than what is there?
You know just people work on all the thousands of hours of audio and video
That's there in the archive 50 times more in a year's time. We can multiplied by 50 that much material is there
He said Satguru already. What is there here? You're throwing it all over the place. It's worth a billion dollars. I
Said see what will I do with the billion dollars my interest is seven billion people I have no interest in billion dollars
What do I do with it?
my interest is people rule number seven strive for a better life as a generation if you create a
Huge amount of positives a negative
Will become small if you create huge amount of negatives. They will become big and positive will become small this whole life is
There has never been a point any time and there never will be where everything is perfect
Okay, there's no such thing
Because life is a possibility because it's a possibility it cannot be perfect
Doesn't matter what we do is still something more to do
always
That is why it's an endless possibility
Striving does not mean. I want to be a good man. I want to be a good man she being
Morally good, he's only good for the society not good for the human being
Yes
If you are morally correct it's good for people around you
Because you contained
But it's not good for this life
So this life needs a little different kind of nurture in that context
How many people in this world are?
Going to stop before you and may fall
dead
How many people in how many people will be set the seed that they will be striving to be a better life than the way?
they are right now a
little higher expression of life
This is all your focus should be rule number eight don't pass on bad things the Japanese people eat
much less fat
Than the Americans and the British
because of this people believe
they have much less incidence of
cardiac arrests
less people in Japan die of
heart failures and heart attacks than they do in UK and in United States
But the French
Eat a lot more fat, but still they have much less incidence of
Cardiac problems compared to the British and the Americans
The Japanese people don't drink much wine so they have much less cardiac problems
But the Italians drink only wine
And they also have much less cardiac problems than the English and Americans
So the deduction is it is the English language which is the problem?
Thing was speaking which is the problem?
So this has been a problem everywhere that
We try to transplant, what is happening in one place simply as it is in another place?
Not just geographically and culturally
even from individual to individual
That what worked for one person
We try to make it work for another person and destroy the person completely
And fortunately, this is labeled as education
mass producing people
Though we are a mass of people on this planet a huge number over 7 billion people
Stealing you were produced individually not mass-produced. Are you right from my childhood. I've been noticing this
that
Most adults want to teach something when they see children
All those damn things which have not worked in their life
This is one wow you have to take with me that is from this moment onwards in your life
You will not pass on anything. That is not worked for you to anybody else
Hello
Even if you cannot pass on the best things to other people at least what is not worked for you
You don't give it to anybody. Will you do this?
Does anger work for you
So don't give it to anybody
Does misery work for you?
This depression work for you
So if you are angry if you're depressed you're miserable just shut up
okay, and
Sit in one place and handle it rule number nine. Don't try to be intuitive people start developing these things
for everything when their logic fails
They will think that
You know you want to do something. You don't know how to do it
You're not sure whether to do it or not do it then the simple solution
They're taking is okay this finger
Is this this finger is this? Yes? No give it to the child if he holds this yes if he holds this not
This is not into
Your laugh Allah, no I will come to you. I am NOT. I am going more basic
The answer is not just about you. I'm just using it
Now this is just that your logic has become
You know incapable its collapsed
Unable to come to your logical decision so you are succumbing to this simple way
If some child holds your hand like this or like this yes or no
Anyway when there are two options 50% of the time you could be right?
Yes
Being 50% of the time right is not good enough isn't it yes isn't it so I
Was you know
Some time ago. I was visiting a a homeopathic doctor
There in his clinic they put up an ad some homeopathic medicine, which will work for all kinds of snakebites
You're living in Bombay proverb probably it's not easy for you where I come from snakes are everywhere on a daily basis
So I looked at this and then I asked him how come
this medicine you are advertising that it works for all kinds of snake bites because
If you are not already aware of this snake bites are fundamentally two kinds
one type of venom attacks your
cardiovascular system
Another kind of venom attacks your nervous system the two completely different kind of chemicals, and it works upon your system in a different way
Generally for both you have different types of antidotes, but for everything this particular medicine is supposed to work. How is that possible?
So the doctor said see in India
90% of the Indian snakes have non poisonous so 90% of the time it works
That's not good enough isn't it if the remaining 10%, which is crucial isn't it?
so
intuition
Don't get into this thing about you trying to be intuitive
never try to intuitive
Logic is dependable isn't it?
There are moments when there is certain clarity, which has no logical explanation at that time
It's okay
But you'll never try to be intuitive if you try to be intuitive your logical mind will become
deceptive and come to all kinds of stupid
Decisions you'll get certainly guidance voices from the heaven. You know all kinds of voices people are hearing
Logic is dependable go by it at least you won't make a fool of yourself
And rule number 10 the last one before a very special bonus. Clip is get into nature if you can find a place
Where there are no?
sounds of machines and
Your cell phone will not think think
Quietly if you can listen to the sound of the trace the breeze the water
Just the natural sounds if you pay enough attention
Tremendous things will happen to you
many times have been in
the south engine
You know they're kind of tropical rainforest
The longest I've been there through the jungle for about 23 days alone no any kind of support
no cellphone for sure those days then not even a torchlight and
Fourth day I ran out of the food that I was carrying so I lived off the forest
Man Bob ate today, I lost my jacket and one half of my shirt
Because I was chased by some animals in by that whole thing. I had half a shirt and pants
And I walked through ice this is elephant country tiger country
Iso tigers panthers elephants all kinds of the wild buffalo various kinds of animals very close quarters?
But
At the end of it when you look back
What is the biggest impact on you? It's the insects. It's in the nights the orchestra
That goes on in the rainforest
It's unbelievable and the timing every day not
2:15 means one group will stop and another group will start
Really the sense of time
every day
Exactly by the second one group will start another group will start
You don't know what they're talking about
They're definitely talking something that you don't know for sure they're not just making dumb noises
So if you just sit there and listen and listen and listen and listen
Roli you start noticing there is a pattern and an organization to this
Which is far bigger than any human?
symphonies that you can achieve
Far more complex and
Far more intense, I think it's very important for every human being
Particularly if you have children
Vacation need not be Disneyland. I'm not against it, but one trip is enough all silly stuff, which excites you
Vacation should be into nature if you can take your children walk in a jungle not in a result
Just live in a mountain expose them to nature, I will tell you you will bring up your children
not only physically healthy mentally healthy far more sensible and accepting and
Wonderful kind of human beings if they know how to because once you go into nature
Whose son you are whose daughter? You are. What are you in the city doesn't matter, okay?
It's very important that everybody experiences that otherwise
You start creating your own illusions as to who you are and you start believing it for sure
Now I've got a very special sadguru bonus clip on how to stop raising the bar of survival
But before that I want to know what did you learn from this clip? What did you learn from these video hoes?
What did you learn from Sadhguru today that you're going to somehow apply to your life or to your business?
Please leave it down the comments below. I'm really curious to find out. Thank you so much for watching
I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in yourself, and whatever you're one where it is much loved see you soon, and enjoy the bonus clip
Let's say taking United States as an example. This is not going to be the problem of only United States United States has
come first in the race
Okay
Others will get it because they're all going the same way
Right now u.s.. Is a stop example
One thing is we go on
raising the bar for survival
We must define this is survival this means you're good enough
After this it must be exploration of what you really wish to do
But we keep on raising the bar of survival in such a way
Now even after becoming the most affluent nation a whole lot of people are just struggling for survival
This is senseless an
Affluence affluence means your survival is done thing isn't it
But like you just mentioned
There is working three jobs to survive
This is not affluence. This is horrible poverty at least in India we can sit back and enjoy
See the way we have structured the society right now is
people have a 35 year house mortgage I
Mean if you have a 35 year economic commitment to something
tomorrow even if
God popped up here. You can't change the direction of your life because the bank is here
What will you do because largely you're all from Christian community, so I am saying
If Jesus popped up tomorrow, and he says come follow me
You're not going
Because
We got monthly payment you
Got bills to pay
Insurance to pay you can't change. This is a silly way of organizing our lives
the question the very reason why we want to become affluent is
so that
Depending upon what Life offers us we can change the direction of our life whenever we want isn't it?
Isn't it very important?
This is one thing that has to sink into the American people being the most affluent nation means
You are not battling for survival
This is happening because you are raising the bar of survival endlessly no matter what you do. You're still only fighting for survival
If this one thing we change then we can do lot of things about health and well-being and beyond that
Raise your standard
Apple at the core is core value is
that
That people passion
Not one drop of myself work depends on your it's suppose to mean I don't ever give up. I'd have to be dead
Or completely incapacitated hey believe nation if you want to see my all-time
Favorite top ten gross a success. I have a very special secret video for you
These are the individual Clips that I have personally learned the most from and applied to my life and my business
Check the link in the description for details